dearest queen you are mad
giving me a palace it is a monstrous
extravagance mrs. Molly we are at war we
won which is not over you must continue
oh oh I did not know that the queen is
an extraordinary person they were all
staring weren't they
I can tell even if I can't see and I
heard the word fat and ugly no one but
me would dare and I did not
she's been stalked by tragedy everyone
leaves me he dies
[Music]
I apologize for my appearance I hoped I
might be employed here by you as
something a monster for the children to
play with perhaps it is important to
make new friends in court is it not yes
a beautiful stop it out you mock me if I
were a man I would have ravish you you
have become close to Abigail she is a
Viper
you're jealous you send up again away I
didn't want to bet shoot something
sometimes it is hard to remember whether
you have loaded the pellet or not you
must take control of my circumstance
always favor is a breeze that shifts
Direction all the time then in an
instant you're back sleeping with a
bunch of scabrous [ __ ]
as it turns out I'm capable of much
unpleasantness
[Music]
good use look at me
I could not just stand by and let you
destroy me joy it is fun to be queen
some
if you do not go I will stop kicking you
will not stop my dear friend how good to
see you've returned from hell
I'm sure you shall pass through it one
day
[Music]
you